welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
bosson who the hell were the 10 Rings
calling back in December 2021 Marvel
drafted a huge setup in the shuni post
credit scene that could have referred to
anyone from galatis to that big Earth
pimple that still no one is talking
about but when the 10 Rings showed up in
the origin point of the bangle in an
episode of M Marvel the Assumption was
that they'd be tied to both Quantum
bands the ancient cre Empire and that
Carol danver's appearance in that shuni
post credit scene meant that this would
be resolved in the Marvel film nope so
if it wasn't the cre and the Marvels one
would assume it must be connected to the
events of Avengers 5 that would make
sense back in the time shanqi was made
because it was directed by Dustin Daniel
keton who was for a Time the assigned
director to the fifth Avengers film
that's no longer the case and now with
Marvel's dropping Jonathan Majors we
don't even know if it's going to be a
Kang story but then again we have been
getting rumors that colan Domingo might
be considered for a recast for the
character of Kang the Conqueror so maybe
Kang is still in the mix Marvel has
invested a lot in that character but
either way the finale for what if season
2 is established that there is a link
between the god of stories Loki and
other Nexus beings like The Watcher and
I think within those wavelengths Loki
might be the one now hearing these rings
as the god of stories and the possible
ranking all father of the MCU he is at
the center of everything within the ETR
still worlds tree and while the Rings
may have been intended for someone else
originally Loki is now the one hearing
them in order to recruit characters like
shangi and his growing multiversal
lineup of Team Loki so I'm going to
break all this down based on some
exclusive insight about the origin of
the quantum bands and the origin of the
tin Rings revealed to me by Iman bani
okay quick recap the tin Rings were
weaponized by wimo for over a thousand
years and their origin was described in
the opening narration of the film but
only
[Music]
apocryphally the Rings transferred to
Shi and Wong brought him and Katie back
to com in the post credit scene to
investigate these Rings they don't match
any artifacts from our codex they're not
vibranium chori not like any alien Tech
I've seen how long did your dad have
them before he gave them to you about a
thousand years they thermal luminesence
indicates they're older than that by a
lot Wong says the first time shuni used
these Rings they felt it in cage and
then he zooms into his projection of the
Rings to reveal this pulsing Beacon a
beacon they're sending a message
a message to where the next sighting of
the 10 rings in the MCU came in M Marvel
episode 3 when the clandestines from the
nor Dimension found one of the quantum
bands on a severed blue arm in a cave in
British occupied India in 1942 you heard
what that man from the temple said he
said we would need two and then an
overhead shot of this cave shows the
markings of the tend rings on the cave
floor now at the time we all speculated
that this was pointing to a shared cre
ancestry between the Bengals and the 10
rings and that perhaps the 10 rings
Beacon was summoning the cre led by we
later learned darbin to come attack
Earth to reclaim the Bengal but then
when the Marvels came out the 10 rings
in the quantum B's history never were
fully explained in fact when I asked
Iman fani about this she claimed that
she had no idea what Marvel was doing
with that 10 Rings reference in M Marvel
episode 3 The 10 Rings thing in our show
I don't know who that whose idea that
was why I mean there I'm sure someone is
smart in plotting something to do with
shangi but I I genuinely I have no idea
and for what it's worth season 2 of what
if established that the 10 rings at
least in Another Universe really did
fall to Earth from the sky from space
and that they represented a kind of
magic that Odin was somewhat familiar
with a magic that he feared being in the
wrong hands and a magic that seemed
evenly matched with his Asgardian magic
so we're talking about a magic or a
technology or both from a Godly place
and perhaps a wavelength that only say a
time God nestled in an Asgardian shaped
tree of time might be attuned to but
Iman and I also talked about the fact
that the Marvel's film did establish the
Bengals as the quantum bands for Marvel
Comics which is a big deal because in
the comics these were worn by quazar and
they were created by Eon who is the
marble Cosmic entity that oversees time
and that these bands were initially
passed down through a lineage of Titans
including Kronos and then his son allars
and allars was the father to Thanos and
AOS Harry Styles and Iman valani
confirmed to me exclusively that an
earlier draft of the Marvel script
revealed that the second quantum band's
resting place on MV 418 was actually the
grave sight of eon I swear there was a
version of our script where darbin
actually named drops Eon like this was
his grave or something where they found
it Eon the Marvel God figure who
oversees time whose statue we saw in the
cosmic dei's chamber in Thor love and
thunder is dead and he was buried on
this planet that could be the
explanation behind that weird golden
marking that they dusted off from the
site on MB 418 oh one shot energy huh I
think I'll try
it
w
[Applause]
so what is one shot Focus sh
do see
it
etern so uh one shot really is all you
need begin your transformation with
oneshot energy today by going to onshot
energy.com neww rockstars for 10% off
your order now if this is still Marvel's
plan it opens up a ton of possibilities
it begins to answer some questions if
the bands were made by Eon as he is in
the comics and if Eon is dead that would
explain why we've only ever seen Cosmic
beings in the MCU of a similar status
like the Living Tribunal in the form of
statues The Living Tribunal was a statue
head that was rotating in Thor 11
Thunder and we saw the Liv tribunal as a
severed statue head in the void in
lowkey season 1 episode 5 so I I believe
that Marvel's god of time and God of law
have been killed and they were killed
not by Gore the god butcher because you
know taati couldn't be bothered to show
a god butcher Butcher Gods but rather
they have been killed by a form of Kang
maybe Kang the Conqueror or perhaps his
future form Kang Prime that could be why
the Multiverse is such a mess the reason
why Wong and Bruce and Carol didn't
recognize the substance of the 10 rings
and the reason Bruce dates them to be
extremely old is that these were
actually engineered with future Advanced
Tech that does not exist yet they were
built by Kang and sent back in time
handed by Kang to various warriors
Heroes and champions to influence
history the Rings to win woo to conquer
Earth the bands to quazar and allars to
conquer the stars in fact that man in
the temple who told the clandestines to
find one of the bands was probably a
Kang variant who wanted that band to end
up in the hands of Kamala Khan so that
she could tear the fabric in SpaceTime
and set that band on a path to create an
incursion to the X-Men Universe in the
Marvel's film both the Rings and the
bands could be made out of quantum ore
that was the mineral that that aim
shovel was designed to dig for in the
very first episode of Loki in the final
scene this was a future tool that syby
left for the TVA to find and if you look
closely at that screen it says aim
Quantum or shovel and it's from the
early 21st century and we know that Kang
has people stored all over time like one
of the Kang variants is pharaoh ramut
who ruled over ancient Egypt an Empire
that would predate win woo and the Loki
series left Ren Slayer in the void with
a pyramid and a sphinx from phoh ramut
time in Egypt so the beacon I don't
think is alerting the cre it's alerting
whatever Kang variant created these
rings and it's pinging that Kang variant
through time to let him know that shuni
finally got his hands on them because
remember Wong said that kamaraj didn't
feel the Rings until shuni used them so
it was less important that when wo had
them it was really Shan's possession of
them that was the trigger which means
that in the original director Destin
Daniel kon's Vision Kang was waiting for
shuni and Marvel Studios intends for
Kang to be waiting for Kamala Khan but
there is a wrinkle in that plan look
closely at the beac it's a flashing
light that courses through several
strands that twist horizontally and now
that we've seen Loki season 2 does this
not look like the flow of time through
the temporal Loom I think that Beacon
was alerting whatever Kang variant is
occupying the throne at the time when we
watched Loki it was he remains it's
trying to alert whoever is in control of
the flow of time but as we know from
watching Loki season 2 the problem with
that plan is now Seated on that throne
with the time stream rotated 90° to
become the form of eil is Loki god of
stories one of the few Gods left in the
MCU at Le gods that are actually doing
anything yeah intended shade thrown at
omnipotent City so this really sets up
Loki as a much more important figure
Kang is selecting one lineup of Avengers
and I think pretty much every Marvel
hero who has done something to break
reality is going to be an Avengers K
Dynasty including shuni doctor strange
Peter Parker Kamala Khan Wanda maximoff
Sylvie and I hope a liveaction version
of kilmonger infinity from what if the
beacon is really meant for Kang but Loki
is intercepting this message and I could
see him gathering this group ahead of
time to warn them that the Kang Dynasty
is on the Move they're about to burn as
many realities out of time to build a
weird creepy compromise amongst all of
them a patchwork of realities into a
shared universe that they can have like
joint custody over so where are the 10
Rings sending a message to I guess
Marvel is probably going to say well not
where but when and the message is meant
for Kang who built these rings and these
Quantum bands who killed Eon and the
Living Tribunal but Loki due to his
recent Ascent is going to hear that
message first so what do you think about
this Theory comment down below support
new rockstars by grabbing something from
nerd. shop thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time bye
[Music]
he